this episode was recorded as part of a
live packs panel hello
everyone wow we're doing an intro at the
top of the show
oh that's weird this reminds me actually
of something i remember hearing about
jerry goldsmith austin
what did you remember this this
if anybody would just like notice that
it was there and would not ever comment
on the fact that you have
the sheet music and book the what is
that called a book book sheet the
conductor score of
yeah well you called me out you're like
she knows like it's the conductor
what does that call it's a piano book
what did you call it what would you call
it it's the it's the conductor score
it's like people orchestration
uh it's not a piano book no conductor's
gonna walk up to the podium and go here
you go and tonight they're going to open
that book up
well you bought that at the bar i
saw austin conduct before i actually
spoke to austin
yeah by by years and what i love is that
you didn't we never established that
until we'd already known each other for
quite some time
wait what how do i not know this story i
conducted in brisbane before she moved
to the us
yeah so i helped the brisbane symphony
orchestra organize
a live video game thing i was connecting
them with pr to like
get trailers and stuff when i was still
working in the games industry in
australia and then austin conducted that
uh show so i went there with my mum and
watched
so technically we worked together yeah
but we didn't meet
no never met never met so i'm gonna i'm
gonna commandeer this for just a second
if i may um i would have it no other way
please well
uh in in in direct uh in direct
uh defiance of alana's suggestion that
we not watch the stream
if you look in the chat i have pasted a
link to the stream
yes and i need you all to open the
stream
and and make sure he's just rebelling
he's just rebelling immediately
it's a coup d'etat you'll obviously need
sound on we're reaching out to a new
audience austin we're finding a new
audience
yeah can i just bring this in a little
bit nope let's see yeah
guys please no because people are
you you can trust me okay so
are you all watching the stream and you
have sound on i am and i'm watching a
very intense ad
oh all right well then give it a give it
a second give it a second
let me know when you're ad free i need
to make the leap apparently
we know who doesn't subscribe to pax now
uh
can i at least mute this because this is
going to drive me crazy no no well the
at
yeah add yes but once that is over
unmute okay
oh okay are we all good
yeah all right josh
go ahead
yes our intro to the show are you done
you made an intro yeah
our intro to today's show hello everyone
welcome to another episode of play watch
listen
let's walk you through this i want to
contextualize all of this
i have a question before you answer that
hi everyone welcome to another episode
of play watch listen i'm alana
i am joined by austin wintery troy baker
and mike bickle
i'm on if i can tangent um tangents are
so welcome
[Music]
voice actor mike is a game director and
austin is a composer
and we discovered hey we all don't hate
each other let me introduce this
thumbnail
[Music]
hold on before you do that i have one
question from mike bethel
actually i have a question for you
play watch listen i'm milan i've been in
games media for like eight years
i already know the answer to this once
you work in an industry
you have just you just have a different
perspective
that's that's how it works miyamoto's
got a gun
[Music]
there's a continuum from the silk
dressing round to the like
the furry dressing out statistics uh
from every study i've read say that that
is not true
i work long hours but i get to own a
company like if you're
reviewing something that's really
complex and you have to give it a score
that's the part that i always dread
there it is joel
dying was not a punishment
nor was his living a reward it simply
was the whims of this world
granting him another day or not i don't
think there's any moment of this
conversation that mike and i don't feel
some level of exactly
so
oh my god i'm only gonna i'm not
usually gonna do this but i do want to
cut off the star wars episode
if you read marks like communism on
paper it makes a whole lot of sense
this much mountain ride in disney is
named not for anything in the ride
itself but because of the movie splash
starring tom hanks
a bunch of [ __ ] you're selling out
to the man if you can afford an
orchestra i said i have a bunch of
really wacky ideas
um but uh they are
um not likely to make you any money
okay hold on before we get too far down
this road
just as a tangent within it it's
obviously rare that troy says no
if ghost of tsushima is is perceived as
a bigger game than last of us two
who cares how much you guys hold up hold
up don't just just like gloss over that
uh video games it's so good the early
demos of almost every game we've made
you wouldn't recognize them
compared to what the final game was
that's by definition wasted work
and iterating iterating iterating
iterating iterating iterating iterating
polish polish polish polish polish
polish polish
nice this is an industry of professional
problem solvers
i don't want to lose massive blockbuster
single-player titles but it's not a
simple matter of if you make the game
half the length
it takes long interesting anyway i'm
being overly long-winded here
i love this this is why i love this
[ __ ] park
[Music]
who made that austin that was that was
awesome
i have uh i have a uh fabulous assistant
dallas who's good with the
video editing and motion graphics and so
i went and sourced a bunch of clips and
said
i arranged it all in a timeline and sent
it to him as audio and was like now sync
all the clips to this audio
and uh apps that's amazing well done to
both of you if i play
well i thought i have a i have a
follow-up call to dallas after this
after this oh my
god that was amazing that was absolutely
incredible and i guess i don't need to
intro
the panel now uh just humbly submitting
an
option for your consideration do as you
will i feel like i've overstayed my
welcome i'm gonna be silent for the next
hour
[ __ ] hey can you send that to
everybody so that we can have that for
forever
yeah i'm actually it'll be live on my
youtube channel in like five seconds
amazing thank you so much austin that's
crazy i have no idea what i'm gonna do
with that in the audio version we'll
figure it out it's fine
uh yeah good luck that's more work than
i put into 30 episodes of this show
[Laughter]
most what's our what's our do you even
know like what's our
um ver like our percentage between audio
and video because i feel like most
people
watch us no we still have more audio
listeners than we have
uh video viewers do everybody that plays
us i mean it makes sense because we have
people that watch us people
listen do we have we conquered the play
yet um do
through like uh we have most of our
audience is actually on spotify
um because of the way seo works
we have the opportunity to have a lot
more views on youtube i can spell who
never people who've never uh encountered
the show before so that's
sort of the breakdown and this is
episode 30 which is very exciting
dirty 30. you made it to 30. wait are
all of us 30 except for you alana
yes uh-oh please
yeah troy's been 30 for the last 14 14
years
14 years going strong yeah uh i thought
that i would take this opportunity while
doing you know a live packs panel to a
um ask mike bethel if he's finished the
last of his part two yet
oh i fall out brilliant i have not
actually i've actively
i actually have an update on that i have
made it into season two of the good
place over the last week
i finally hey angela and i were like all
right let's do this thing and
i i i i see upon
cresting the season break of one into
two
it immediately revealed to me what was
the reason
you and everyone else was so excited
yeah
goddamn national treasure oh my gosh
nothing i won't i love you no i but i'll
say this
you know because i think i'm i think we
stopped last night at like episode
four of season two or something the
thing that blew me away
that that if all of season one is like
an extended trailer to season two in
many respects it feels like to me like
they're laying a foundation
that's wacky and silly and then it it
pulls out the rug i know i'm telling you
everything that you've known for years
but the thing that
the thing that i liked was that i
thought okay reboot
we know the premise now we're going to
basically do a new version of season one
and what i love is that in the first
episode
they see that coming and they're like
okay 800 iterations later
and and they just skip past instantly
the careful austin
be careful but yes it and it keeps going
from there
you're going to love it be careful oh my
you'll not need to be careful in terms
of spoilers you're
you're edging closer no he's the last
person who hasn't seen the show
well i know that's the thing i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm yeah i'm exercising
a little diplomatic immunity on that i
acknowledge uh well i started playing a
plague tale
so i wanted to bring to the group i
finally started playing a play tale
uh that's the thing you've been doing
yes no it is a weird game to play right
now for sure um
that having that context like makes it
just feel a lot darker um but
like tails sounds like a really bad
bible game that like came out on
like a pc rom bible game don't feel like
it takes that stance so far
full title is a plateau innocence um
okay
what's it about score is very nice
olivier de riviere
uh i would say thus far it is about two
people
uh living during a time of a plague but
that's loving the time of colorado
[Laughter]
yeah and they do a good job at making
your stomach churn with the
40 billion rats on screen oh yeah nope
i'm out i'm out
i'm out don't like rats how far have you
made it alana are you still pretty early
yeah i'm about two hours in uh it's one
of those that caught me i
i played it i love how troy's just fully
committed to this he's just gone
[Laughter]
i i played it because i was interviewing
the composer for the game makers
notebook
uh podcast and i i realized that i've
known his music
as albums for years but i had i i was
like i don't think i've ever actually
played a single game he's scored
somehow and so i did this binge where i
was like i'm just going to dip my toes a
couple hours
over the course of a week in like 10
different games so i was playing like he
had just done streets of rage four
it's playing um uh you know i'm trying
to remember 11 11.
uh is that what that one's called yeah
eleven memories remember uh
what is it i've got it here and steam
who are you talking a producer off
screen uh
i'm talking yeah i'm talking to which
would be you probably
and uh uh and but then i plagued was the
one that was kind of
like a bigger hit amongst the rest and
then i kept playing and i was like i
actually
feel this burning need to go back and
finish it because i just it got me it
i definitely will i really like boxing
yeah it's yeah and good voice acting too
like i really i find the
i find the little boy like i'm like i
need to protect you you're very you are
genuinely innocent and i just i need to
i need to do what i can troy good
question for you related to
children voice acting is it often
actually a child or isn't it an adult
no dude tara strong um grey delisle
laura
bailey um well even ashley johnson is
considerably older than yeah actually
all right like
um i've done uh in last week i did two
um auditions that i had to do for
children and was just like i ended up
just being like i don't know how to do
this i have no idea what to do
you know what i found by and large to be
true is that
um chris summer has also done a lot
she was um penny in inspector gadget
and she's also uh she was in um
oh what's the family super the family
huh set them up it's fine
penny in a family no she was penny and
inspector gadget
oh and she was a show about family
without the wildeberries
it was a very popular um uh nickelodeon
show i didn't have cable growing up so i
didn't know but it's the
rugrats rugrats thank you so
um the uh a lot of times the
it's it's gonna be like a female that's
doing it yuri lowenthal is one who's
just like perpetually done
you know he was ben 10 so he's done kids
spider-man
um even though yuri is just a little bit
older than me
but the um the interesting thing is
is i find them more believable are the
ones that aren't
kids but actually just play it as
themselves
and then let the picture do the work you
know um
that that's true that would be a little
harder to sell with like say your voice
i've done kids i'd play that game
i play i play the game 12 year old 12
years old
i don't yeah i don't know what loss is
you don't know what loss is
uh i i by and large i don't i don't
typically do kids
i'll do the dad before i do the kids
i'm sorry guys i don't do kids i'll do
the dad
it's a good stance to have i kept it i
kept this wholesome
mike mike is just like and we're gonna
finally use the edit button on our live
stream
you're allowed to say you want to have
sex with dad so it's completely fine
there's a few dads i wouldn't mind
having sex with there you go it's not
that's a problem that's just logical
it's just like everybody's a little gay
too by the way let's just be honest
everyone's a little gay definitely yeah
in fact
i don't know how we got here a lot of
you asked the questions i did ask the
question
yeah i had to do that clear trajectory
you did it you did it
i had to do a child crying twice
actually both of them were children
crying
uh one for a video game and then one
that was like i was doing something else
i finally got to do my robot voice
and they were like can you also cry as a
child it was like
you threw this on me i don't think so uh
so i just didn't i didn't even try it
they didn't say just childhood 18. i
could have done a baby
i think but a child is a whole other
thing that's like a very complicated
thing to even think your way through my
favorite is uh
tommy talarico used to have uh or a few
times he had d bradley baker come to
video games live
concerts where he would be like okay
here's the scenario he'd have the
audience throw it out like okay a baby
transforming into a vampire that is also
part
something and he would he would create
this sound that was
unbelievably convincing of all those
things happening at once it was like
here's what you need to if
for people who don't know and deep
bradley baker is definitely if if
there's a
those guys of film there's those guys at
vo and it's by and large it's
a matter of fact john dimaggio did a
documentary called i know that voice
it's brilliant if you've never seen it
um he chronicles almost everyone from
melbourne forward
um but d bradley baker plays his sinuses
like an instrument like i've literally
seen him in like
sessions he's like what kind of sound do
you want it's like it's this he's like
okay
and you'll see him do stuff like this
and he produces
in the human sense other
[Music]
does the same thing like with his throat
he like physically
and the craziest fever dream notion or
fever dream i've ever had
is seeing uh this was in vancouver
or toronto i think it was in toronto and
it was super late it's almost like three
o'clock in the morning we were in the
lobby of this hotel
we were continuing to drink and there
was tom kinney
trying to teach mike tyson how to do
the spongebob laugh and all this was
definitely
and then i woke up and i realized i
should have had the suit of fed before
but like we were
like mads mikkelsen was there with us
and we were
in and like jason momoa had just passed
away i was like this is a fever dream
um is is
remarkably talented um if you ever need
creature voices right it does well to
the baker name
yeah how do you learn how to do that
kind of thing do you think it's someone
just experimenting
his story is great so he used to play at
the
universal um theme park he was
beetlejuice and it was just like
it's a thankless work but he's just a
he's just a great actor character actor
and mary elizabeth mcglynn we used to
work there as well and she said he would
walk around with a tape recorder
and just learn like what what happens if
i do
this and we just record himself making
all these sounds if dee bradley baker if
it's ever a lull in a session
you will swear that there's a cricket in
the room because he's he's doing the
sound of the crickets and he's just
he's also um he's the fish on
an american dad yeah he's just peckable
german i like he cracks me up
he is he i can't and he also has like a
great resource for people who want to
become voice actors called i want to be
a voice actor.com
and he's just like assault to the earth
he's he's one of the greatest humans
kind hilarious dee bradleybaker.com
i love that he plays his sinuses like
plays the scientists i'd have watched
him do it like he brought in like a
glass tube and i was like what son do
you want is like well they're kind of
like helmeted creatures and so he would
and it was like that's that's processed
he's like that's organic like all this
and he's not playing something that's
consistent with voice actors i've
encountered like i'd say more than most
other professions
the amount of kind of silliness and
playfulness in the moment and how
i don't think this is part being an
actor generally right that kind of
willingness to expose yourself and just
be
really silly and daft and try things and
be creative
i love that i love the number of like vo
sessions where i've got like recordings
of those sessions
and the actor i did one recently where
the actor in between takes
was just doing other characters like in
the booth just to keep
keep keep his voice warm and it was just
it's lovely that playfulness that
experimentation
which is so much fun i love it you know
i did that i kept pitching myself like i
i did that also on bat tails of
um of batman i did the same thing
like telltale tell tells batman
telltale's batman
all the ingredients were there it was
fine yeah you got it yeah i kept doing
like falcone
um and not not like auditioning they're
like we already cast [ __ ] i was like
i know i just like doing the voice it's
just fun
just see if i can do like a lizard bad
force awakens i realized that circus
basically had turned up and done
snoke in the recording booth and i had
no idea i saw star wars oh fair play
yeah you've got you've got a couple runs
out of that voice
some of the best versions of like
characters of
have come from just people like one of
my favorites i think we've talked about
this before peter cullen
was his agent said uh you have a a
session with with fox i think it was
and he was like what is it like they
want to do creature voices like man i'm
blasted like he'd done
a lot of other vo gigs he's just tired
but he went down he got the gig
and so he goes down and they said um so
uh we need to do a creature sound you
know it's an alien
kind of thing and he was like uh what
does it look like it's like we can't
show you
because it's it's confidential he's like
well i can't give you a voice i don't
know what it's supposed to sound like
like
so finally they'd get approval and they
they showed him what they what the
character looked like and he goes oh
okay i got that and they use a
sennheiser 416 which is a shotgun mic
he's like you need to bring that down
closer and they were like
that's where the mic goes he was like i
don't care if you want me to do this
voice you need to bring it closer
drop to like three inches like no no
bring it right here
and he did the sound i can
make sure i can do it
it's a cat a predator predator and that
he did that voice because
he didn't want to scream wait holland's
predator as well really did peter
collins
yeah damn what an instinct like yeah
like the best and the worst i love it
wait wait so did they give him direction
for what they wanted predator to sound
like
nope he said i need to know what the
character looks like they shut he goes
like does those look like the um
hermit crabs that i grew up with on that
i would find by the water and she was
like i know those
those things sound like this and so
that's where you came up with predator
sound
that's super cool i guess this is a
great spot for me to transition into
what i wanted to talk about today um it
is a weird subject to the episode
yes it's a weird week to record because
we have a playstation conference
um and that is happening yeah eight
hundred dollars i reckon
internet nine hundred he's got oh he's
gone up to nine hundred
uh ten thousand hundred us nine hundred
we did our
price predictions last week um so
potentially if that conference is meaty
enough we'll have to catch up on that
next week oops
uh but we did we're also a week late on
this topic
which is uh the june trailer
um austin i know i i we spoke about it a
little bit last week that you're a huge
fan
of dune i just bought the book i haven't
started reading it yet
i would call myself a a big fan not a
huge fan
uh but only because i read it as a kid i
loved it
five meters yeah exactly oh no what's
the difference between big and huge
one is like outside but no i understand
that like i don't call myself a star
wars fan
because i feel like that's like a layer
like i'm i
obviously am a person who likes star
wars but i feel like star wars fan is
this like
extraordinary identity right yeah would
not say stan
i stand star wars i'm a stan uh no
because i feel like star wars fan
is like someone who like has a like i
guess i have a darth maul in it is there
is there a name for star wars fans like
the risk for star trek
warzone there would be my favorite is
the focus
no there i don't think there is like i
always liked that what i call
right now they did a whole like uh
ceremony for me
and and inducted me into the 5-0 first i
was like this is a big
deal for me but do you have the full
suit no i'm an honorary member of the
501st
that's cool so i have my challenge coin
i have my badge and i have my full
packet i was like thank you so much
they're like never be caught without
your challenge coin and so far i've
never been
that's very cool huh we'll see we'll see
right now i have a mission
i feel like you don't the star wars fan
doesn't need a term because
star wars fan is everything it's called
human it's just pop culture right
like it's just no my favorite uh term
for those was brown coats for the uh
for the uh joss whedon firefly uh
community
i always liked that yeah they were the
brown coats and self-identifying as a
brown coat
they're coming for you
mostly from a standpoint that i have
become thoroughly
um i have become thoroughly you know uh
betwixt by uh
by um denis valeneuv the director uh
betwixt is not the right word bewitched
by uh better is the better yeah like
you always have whatever happens yeah
exactly you're right you're right i um
he's he's
betwixt to be witched and bedazzled yep
exactly
yeah wait are we talking about dune now
yes well i just i just i just thought
to me yeah it's funny i hear your i hear
your perspective that it ticked all the
boxes of like
cheesy trailer tropes um well okay we
haven't shared that on this show but yes
that was a beef that i had with it was
that it felt it felt very cheesy to me
and i
i almost didn't even want to say that
publicly because everyone's so excited
that i just felt like
like am i missing something about this
that it just looks like very cheesy
sci-fi to me there's a task
whisperer whispered the thing well here
here's the thing
[Laughter]
they can do all of that they can do all
of that except for they bring pink floyd
and i was like all of it
just bring it back and that's where
that's where
that's where for me the the the the
you have to translate between the
conventions of the trailer and like
absorbing the face value of them and
seeing through to the
and the promise of what they are
showcasing because that was where i was
like this looks like a really genuinely
faithful
uh you know kind of uh adaptation of a
novel that has proven
historically elusive uh to to really get
in a way that everybody can agree on
you know like ev every every uh every
adaptation so far has had like its
diehards and then it's massive legions
of like ah that's so
misses it and this one and funny trivia
you wanna trivia we're not ready for
christmas yet
trivia about uh dune is
that um it's funny i had a friend write
that they said i hope
that um that theater going
experience becomes a thing because the
four movies that i want to see this year
in the theater
are wonder woman 1984 tenet
dune and the new james bond and i said
here's something funny
three of the four of those were scored
by han zimmer and tenet which normally
would be because he's done all of
um all of nolan's movies for more than
10 years now uh
tenet would have been but he went with
ludwig gorinson
because hans was so tied up on dune
and he basically the word on the street
was that han said this is the
one like he read that book however many
decades ago and said if anyone ever
makes a proper movie of this then
i will basically not take no for an
answer like i must be it's my ultimate
bucket list score to write
wow so he so supposedly hans literally
said to nolan
i'm not available because i'm
on dune now so it's like when i look
when i read a thing like that and then i
see you know they had those initial like
oscar isaac uh
still that came from the set however
many months ago and zendaya
all like super cool production
i was like all of that looks really teed
up and then and then yeah then you see
the giant
worms and it's like all right i think
that they've probably done it justice
i'm gonna i should re-read it
so what is it about doing that people
really love
yeah i wish i had a good art i should i
should have
an articulate answer then it's just the
worm in it i think it's because i think
isn't it also isn't it also appeal the
same way that the game of thrones books
appeal that it's like
genuinely sophisticated political yeah
okay my business partner's a big fan and
he yeah alexander he loves
he loves dude and i think part of that
yeah is the intrigue is
imagining the political houses and that
kind of mix of
feudal and and this case basically it's
a story about drug dealing
federal dynasties right like it's
basically this fascinating
people on planets i've never i've never
read it but it sounds cool
i'm looking forward to the movie this
trailer surprisingly he's never really
like
my story i think the writers got like
yeah well i don't read any of these
books they're props for a conversation
wait do you not have a copy of dune back
there i don't think i do know
i think you found the game we did it
yeah we finally found
30 episodes but we did it
no i thought oh no
it's like this thick it's like it's like
a
and that was the thing i think was
off-putting as a kid i was a bit
overwhelmed by it
oh wait i thought turn that sideways
turn that sideways she can't because i
came back i have it turn that sideways
turn your book sideways
okay that's not that so it's it's like
what 600 pages isn't that right oh i
mean
well don't forget there's like a million
sequels yeah
that's people sometimes suggest against
you have to read it yeah it's kind of
like ender's game
uh right oh really just kind of but it's
also very dense right it's very densely
written there's lots of made up silly
words and very strange i remember that i
think as a kid that just overwhelmed me
i couldn't get through it
um i don't know man i'm i opened one
page and the names that i have are
paul and jessica i'm out it's
fine i
my father had been a big fan of it and
he evangelized for the book for me and
his selling point was you will never
appreciate a glass of water more than
after you read this book
uh that was the way he sold it to me and
i remember they made a big impression
that they wear these things called the
still suits that
that have the you know extreme obsessive
recycling of all
bodily waters to the point that uh you
you just dehydrate at
you know exponentially slower rates uh
as a result and and
just the the the thinking about the
mechanism of that as a kid was
somehow unforgettable of just like what
would it take to survive an environment
like that
can i pivot on the subject of speaking
in uh of and surviving in an environment
one of my i'm totally derailing us in a
different direction but just
today's big news that that as someone
who has a
massive pet peeve for this today has
what in one universe represents the
biggest news story in the history of
news stories but
because venus the [ __ ] drives me nuts
i got you that venus [ __ ] drives me
nuts austin victory everybody
here was here was the new york times
headline astronomers have found a
potential sign of life in the clouds of
venus
a potential long overlooked a planet
long overlooked
in the search for extraterrestrial life
and then the subheading is scientists
have detected a chemical called
phosphine in the thick venous atmosphere
after much analysis they assert
that something now alive is the only
explanation for the chemical source
something now still alive something
currently alive creating phosphate
products which which is basically farts
bacteria or whatever
yeah well it's i mean so the thing that
i can't stand about that
is that you know it then says they give
lip service to the real story which is
some researchers question this
hypothesis
uh and the fact that like the click
baity science headline
stuff is the it's like supposed to be
the one bastion
safe from garbage uh clickbait of course
i immediately go to carolina science
journalism's been a bit like that for a
while in fact
oh it's awful it's the worst science
journalism
it's awesome you're competing with a
million things like i get it no it's
going to be sexy i read the article it's
it's it's awful and the funny thing is i
i of course i immediately go to carolyn
porco's twitter because
carolyn porco our mutual friend who was
uh the
lead imaging scientist of the cassini
probe that dove into saturn and her big
baby was studying
enceladus the moon of saturn that was
jettisoning uh these ice geysers full of
organic material where they're going
this water may be a liquid ocean
powered by geothermal sources on the
moon of enceladus and
if there's anywhere in our solar system
that shows the most promise for
um independent biogenesis event um
it would be oh yeah there it is
um it would be the moon of enceladus and
so that's been her big push is like we
need to send another probe
to go ice fishing uh and uh but
apparently venus has only a single
i don't think i've ever seen this alana
that one's
oh blends right in uh that's not fair a
lot of makers look good
thank you that's not fair this is my one
skill make glasses
i can wear glasses i'd just like to
point out these are not a prop
i do use them but
so is that your way of saying that when
we record this show that you just you
have to go on sound
off who's who there's no disturbing and
not knowing what's on your glasses these
aren't like
these are like those those glasses that
keep up blue light by the way i don't
actually wear glasses
but there's nothing more disturbing to
me than not knowing what's on what's
smudged on your lenses
your fingers considerable it doesn't
it's but it's not coming off so
i'm not grossed out anyway i consider it
i consider it my civic duty to say there
is absolutely no confirmation of life on
venus don't fall for the headline trap
it is a
it is an intriguing get out of the
spaceship i i read this
new york says was like hey here's this
thing
the only way it's it's not like
clickbaity to me it's like
look the this this specific thing that
we're finding trace amounts of
is representative we it's nothing that
agriculturally
or geographic or uh agriculture would be
quite something
can be can be produced and the only way
that we have found this specific thing
actually but that's no but that's that's
what's wrong that's and here was the
tweet
that i was led to by carolyn porco which
is from
professor lee cronin
and um who wrote i think we need to
teach astrobiologists
a bit more organic and physical
chemistry starting with the heats of
formation and hess's law
which carolyn parker was confirming to
say it actually is entirely
geophysically capable
geophysically possible to produce
phosphine without requiring essentially
you know microbial life to create it as
a byproduct by the way this is
national geographic that is tweeting
this out
something weird is happening in the
clouds of the planet next door but some
experts are raising doubts about the
quality of the data
it's not clickbaity well that no that's
a good headline that's a good one all of
the uh headlines i can see here austin
are parading things
a gas found on earth that signifies life
has been detected in the clouds of venus
that's not saying there's life um
astronomers find possible sign of life
on venus is a bit click-baity but saying
possible means what they're saying is
not a lie
on venus mysterious traces of gas tease
the possibility of life like
it's well the headline i got was that
was the new york times
the new york times is currently like one
venus question mark astronomers see
phosphine signal in its clouds yeah fair
enough fair enough it's caused by farts
caused by thoughts no space faults
that's why that's all you need to do is
just add the word space to it
anyway i i i know i know i'm taking i'm
taking us off
i'm taking this off it's just that was
one of those that i was looking for
since been talking about dune which i
also wanted to follow up and ask like
why do we think that this particular
thing that doesn't seem like it is that
mainstream
popular has been iterated on this many
times what is it about
dune again not being necessarily
inherently guaranteed to make money
because i don't know that dune is like
pop culture
like right on the forefront of things uh
well
was lord of the rings before those
movies of comparable
sort of nerd culture saturation like i
feel like those books were not
were not in on every human being's
bookshelf and they still justified a
there was a hundred million dollar yeah
but there was also was it like
what go ahead i just mean that the
multiple iterations for dune is what i'm
saying like if you haven't made a lot of
the rings
like with three different people or
whatever well they have there was the
animator there was the animated versions
uh and uh that was not existing there
you go oh it was 40 years before you
were born so
it's in fairness yes thanks i appreciate
that um
that yeah that one does not age
particularly well in my estimation
um musically included it's it's uh it's
it's one of those that you wish
even the score could could hold up and
it really doesn't leonard rosenman
uh sadly but uh them out go for it roast
them all
dude how do you know that it's time it
was the time i got the insult
austin who was the composer on uh ishtar
on ishtar got nothing
here we go we should have made it up i
did it yeah
we wouldn't have i got you i got bethel
on the bookshelf when i got awesome on
the composer it's true
i'm quite proud that i have an astro
biology book that is
that's i'm sorry i didn't solve it
how are we talking about playstation
dave grueson is the composer on ishtar
i mean we can't talk about playstation
uh but it's
like i said immediately outdated by the
end of this week if we talk about that's
fun
we can talk about how wrong we are give
all right give me your your
um 100 correct things say it as though
it's already happened
about the playstation conference design
uh yes i remember so well when they
revealed the playstation 5 price
and it was exactly
mike was in this one that's crazy don't
know what he was doing there but
they just showed up i was i also really
hosted by greg miller yeah to uh not to
uh be overly self-congratulatory i was
also in the ubisoft fast forward
uh uh the highlights you were the
highlight on thursday
with their vr game agus uh oh cool i had
the pleasure
scored that ages ago glad it's finally
glad it's fine did you have one
personally or
you personally were on it they had one
of those great clips of austin going
video games are amazing just just video
games are amazing
i guess yeah in that sense sadly not
that was my that was my true peak moment
in life was being told
i was i was telling you expect the
unexpected uh i was very excited to see
you there it was very cool
um it was mostly a lot of wait what him
who's that guy not so much excitement
but but bewilderment like wow i guess
they
i guess they pulled that together very
last second and he was the only one who
was like i'll do it
here's a question yes i'll do it to to
austin's wonderful introduction which
changed more
austin's facial hair
or my
like what do you think was the most i
was looking through that what what
changed the most because like it was
your background or this or the state of
austin's face
[Laughter]
like your background's changed i think
i've stayed exactly the same
uh throughout the year
chair has changed twice in fact um
there were two noticeable things that i
had forgotten about uh
to that question when putting that
together which was
i i found a few quotes that i liked from
the first episode and then was very
annoyed that that was the one where it
just had text on screen the whole time
saying there's no video this time
yes and so i had to i had to b-roll
around that uh with dallas to to make
you realize that you're hearing audio
from episode one but you're not looking
at episode one in order to solve that
problem and then subsequently we had a
few
where whoever was talking was giant uh
the skype days yes
the skype the skype the skype error did
we start on skype
yep i think right yeah well i just
remember the complaints
all everyone was upset that alana was
too small that was just consistent do
anything about it that's right
it's like consistently the issue i
didn't have a choice what was i supposed
to do
that was one of those that was one of
those humbling moments of recognizing
the the pecking order of why people are
are uh i don't think that's quite it i
think it's more satisfying to see
everyone's reactions be equal like i
don't think it's necessarily i'm sure
they prefer to look at trolls they're
gracious
it's very great based on the comments
even on the live streams people are
talking about what i love is like
there's been so many moments when i've
said something
and it's the reaction i'm trying to
remember what episode it was where both
at the same time simultaneously alana
and mike's reaction
to whatever i said was like almost equal
it's like their head cocked to the same
side
i i love being able to see like because
there's even stuff that i miss
and like going back and and re-watching
or re-listing i was like
oh there's actually something that a lot
of times it's it's something that mike
said
because i'd typically tune him out in
the first time through it
i'm sorry weird buzzing in my ear what
was that with a slight british
aristocracy
you know what's so funny about that
exact point you're making is i showed
i showed the uh i showed the video to
angela and uh the moment in the video
where mike says
i work long hours but it's but it's okay
because i i get to own a company
and we kind of superimpose this like mr
money bag yeah
because of just how fast-moving it is
she missed the point
and i said did you like the thing there
and she goes i thought that was just
because he's british
i was like yeah i mean that's if you
walk around london that's just that's
everybody
i mean ultimately we create art other
people bring their own meanings to their
heart right like we don't know
at that point it's very important people
can put what they want to put onto it
onto it
wow real game director [ __ ] out here
look at him go
um but related i do actually speaking of
art
we gonna have t-shirts
what this is this is my first time
seeing this
i thought yeah i feel like i'm on an
episode of like like oprah winfrey's
going to come out
and this is going to shine a quick audio
pick up here to let you guys know these
dropped
today on redbubble.com people slash play
watch listen
all one word we are making five percent
profit from every single
sale of anything that you buy because
there's more than just t-shirts
and literally all of it will be donated
to charity kick ass
that's awesome do we get free t-shirts
no because red bubble doesn't work like
that i would still have to pay for them
watch
yeah because they walk us through the
design there that's that's a hand
holding a cup
correct it's a hand holding i guess i'm
doing it the wrong way around apparently
modeled off of austin's hand
yeah that's angela made those and that's
yeah you can see actually you can see
the the difference
yeah and are these so walk me through
the colors
like those so they're transparent
meaning that uh on redbubble you can
choose to have like any color t-shirt
that you want for our audio listeners
um i'll post a photo on probably twitter
and instagram if you want to come check
it out
but uh basically you can have any shirt
that you want uh meaning that the color
of the
the mug will be whatever color of the
shirt you've chosen uh can also do
hoodies like they have just tons of
customization i'll also do stickers for
them as well in case anyone wants one of
those but
yeah a bunch of different color options
she chose all of them i was like
i just want a hand holding a mug that
says play watch listen the rest is up to
you
um so yeah those will drop friday i'm
very very very excited to see people
wearing them
me too hopefully i'm gonna get one i'm
gonna go i've been recognizing the
street from this podcast the other day
and if i'd been wearing this t-shirt i
would have been recognized twice is it
true yeah it's the first time it's
happened with this show yeah genuinely
someone came up to me i was wondering
where the black guy came i love the show
yeah yeah i was just gonna
you beat me to it i was gonna make the
same exactly
austin and i are just like synced up man
today um
i i look just in retrospect this is
clarity alana beat me to it i was gonna
make it on the street
everyone gets credit for everything i
say it's fine kind of
30 episodes 30 weeks of
beautiful issues yeah i mean that's
that's that's all this has been
incredible and the things that i've
learned about each 28 weeks i think in
two months or
whatever yeah love it love it
this is that is the most play watch
listen response to troy saying a nice
thing by the way which is
just correct on the other dates yeah
that's good
i just i just i just felt the mirror on
myself and suddenly was like oh [ __ ]
every group has one and it's me god damn
it i think it's like a little bit off
it's all of us it's all of us i i love
that this thing was born
out of um just how um seemingly
haphazard this is
this has come about um like alana and i
you and i first
hung out in san diego we had i met you
when i was very drunk
we were we were all drunk diner food i
mean i had known you
for a while before then like via the
internet
but um this was i was telling you about
how i have trouble playing
jazz on piano uh because something about
uh i remember this conversation we're at
a diner eating
shitty diner food while drunk after a
party and i just i had trouble playing
jazz because something about like the
lack of structure i don't really i don't
really know like i just find the flow of
jazz difficult and you were like you
just gotta let it go
man it's like he's right i do have to
just let it go that sounds like me after
a night of drinking
what's the in la la land none of that
free jazz [ __ ] jake isn't that jk
it's like the restaurant owner or
whatever devil's music no idea um
and then mike bithell for me i mean i
don't want to dominate this but like
mike bithell for me
being your fifth choice and then that
bringing you guys
before that you met me before that i
don't think you remember it we were we
were
back-to-back
i like where this is going we were back
to back in a uh
imagination wonder was it london comic
con there was a comic con and like you
were there with one of the
marvel lego games i think and i was
there with volume
and i remember we met we we met in a
corridor and i just basically fanboyed
at you for five minutes you were very
friendly to me it was very nice
and then we moved on with our livestream
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah nice
interaction with you before
we knew each other each other i think
was at the ign office and
he reached out to me afterwards and said
sorry if i was rude
and i had no recollection of you being
rude at all yeah i was like
sorry this is me being british that's
the most
by the way what was brilliant about this
the lad was leaving off because
she probably didn't notice because again
this is something that happened entirely
in my head
she didn't reply for like three or four
days to the dm
and mike's just like getting the ropes
i was like hates me because i'm a
terrible human being i was just like
what
i don't think you i don't even i don't
have no recollection of anything you
could have even done that was rude i was
like
you were just so generally unmemorable
that's it i spent roughly half my life
apologizing in fairness
that's very british but you know related
to this uh us
you know thinking back or whatever uh i
am going to take questions now if anyone
would like to ask them we've never done
a q a before
um i know we did lose some people from
the stream sadly because the connection
was having problems
um but there is a discord server there
was at the start yeah
so i can take them on youtube where we
did get a question from ducky maverick
who said
do they ship internationally the shirts
yes
uh they will ship anywhere in the world
yeah um again i have no control over how
much redbubble
will charge for that i don't even know
uh it could be a bummer
but hopefully it's not too bad um so
yeah you guys can leave questions if you
would like in there
i don't know what i'm gonna title this
episode it's just a retrospective right
it's like that that's not going to work
on youtube troy
sorry i don't know how it works a retro
aol you can call it you can call it play
watch listen the musical
and one hour post lead i do really like
someone someone in someone in the
comments i'm gonna give them credit
was uh ice ray42 said dune and other
space farts
i thought that was pretty strong spicy
space farts is always smart
space monsters
venting venting about space farts
venting space spots
oh that's i do like that i can't do it
but i like it
uh giham said do you guys ever have a
plan to have guests on
we've discussed this at length and uh
my take on that is generally look this
is a show about the chemistry between
us for as people who very much respect
each other
and uh willing to disagree with each
other and have all right [ __ ] off mike
and have similar senses of humor that i
think it works and i think if you
removed one of us and you put someone
else in i
genuinely think it would feel like an
entirely different show
it wouldn't be this group of people with
an extra person cool it would literally
not be
play watch listen anymore it would
fundamentally change the minute we added
someone else in
um i think we probably will do that if
someone absolutely can't do a certain
week uh if needed so we're not again
we've come close a couple of times right
we have
times where that's coming we've thought
about it but for the most part i just
feel like yeah again that that becomes a
different show entirely i don't think it
necessarily makes sense and
i do think it could be interesting to
have someone join the four of us though
um instead of a replacement if we wanted
to
fixate on a specific game for example or
a specific
something that it like someone from that
thing were to come and
and we were all to talk about so it's it
would be unusual for us because we'd go
in
preemptively focused on something but uh
that would be interesting as a periodic
um that was the way i've pictured guests
before you know
i'm certainly not against it um but
yeah it's not something that i'm trying
to do so i guess we'll see certainly
open to being flexible on it um it sort
of sort of depends
how it goes it does join the risk of
those south park episodes where kenny's
dead for the whole season and they keep
auditioning a fourth friend and they're
like
tweet if you want to be our fourth
friend you're really gonna have to act
more like kenny
you know i feel like there's one thing
with with the as i'm looking at the
the art there behind you the play watch
listen there's really
though the fourth one is missing and i
feel like it would be like play watch
listen and wrangle
because that's what a lot of does i try
i do my best
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
uh we got another one from jeff mcrae
that said
what's troy's bathroom story that was
cut several episodes ago
uh oh you don't want to know it was fake
uh we didn't actually cut anything
it was a joke about a thing being cut
that didn't exist i'm sorry to ruin
the mystery that's how the sausage is
made guys
the charlie kaufman esque kind of
process of making this show yeah
uh patrick swinsky asked do you guys
think you will ever do more lives like
this we do them every 10 episodes
so at episode 40 we will do another live
episode they'll probably be on my
channel and on my twitch
um so we certainly have been doing those
they're fun but also sort of scary and
everyone complains about the audio mix
being wrong even though i can't fix it
because it's live
[Laughter]
which by the way mine's gotten
significantly better ever since i
tried you've been through 60 mics and 26
computers you guys have been great like
the last three weeks
audio's been i'm mike number 61.
like your mic's been good too you've
been you've been good you've been trying
to various mics well
he turned he turned the game
down which means that now i can turn you
up more without you blowing out which
was always the problem with people being
like mike's too quiet i'd be like yes
but if i made him
louder it would be terrible no one's
ever complained about that in real life
no one's ever been like mike's a bit
quiet he's not chatting
himself it's true yeah it's true yeah
what if he had more opinions
this is you speak the same way you adorn
your torso with shirts it's
it's proudly out there uh
jacob d 1987 and asked what's the last
game you played that you chose not to
listen to the score
i don't know that i ever do that no that
that is a very
uh that is a very journey possibly
yeah funny enough for this ui to turn it
off you got to mute the whole game if
you want to do that
you contact the music off yeah
absolutely
assassin's creed syndicate um i love
this
all this advertising uh the pathless not
out yet but i immediately john wick
of course i never i still don't know
what the music's like yeah you're not
familiar with it
particularly no i've never never sat
down to listen to it one day i will one
day well
i've heard it's great like i've heard
the music's great uh
what's a game that you've worked on and
or played that you think is amazing but
you don't think enough people have
played it
my answer to this is generally always
dragon's dogma darker risen not that
people haven't played it it's just that
i wish more people played it
i don't even know where to start with
that yeah i feel like troy probably
and has worked on so many things that
like
probably there's some real like secret
classics in your
in your in your background i mean yeah
someone would be like yeah a lot of
people played that but
i'm really proud of tales from the
borderlands and
i feel like a lot of people like the
people that played that are die hard but
it was still
just from a sales perspective wasn't
you know gangbusters numbers it was kind
of like that indie art house
vibe um it's like the it's like the um
rocky horror picture show of games where
there's like people that obsess with it
and 99
have not seen it yet yeah are you jack
what would you play in that that's a
funny story um
no damian clark played jack in
borderlands the thing yeah the actual
proper universe
the telltale no he actually came back
and was jack in our story
so telltale got a bit they licensed that
from
gearbox and they were like we want to do
like uh
out of canon you know uh separate story
and kind of infuse our characters and
and give it our aesthetic and our
treatment and so they
they created this kind of sub-world from
um
all of this that that still had like
hyperion and everything else about it
but and
it wasn't a shooter so it's kind of the
same thing where you like you look at
anybody else who's going to pitch a john
wick game is going to go it's a shooter
it's at least a third-person action
adventure fighter and mike bithell's
accounting person goes nah that's the
small choice that's the smart choice
here's what we do um and so tells
telltale was like what if we made this
like a completely kind of you know
point click adventure kind of thing with
that they do so well with with branching
uh narrative
dialogue uh and so i played rhys in that
and laura bailey played
fiona um can i just say that that
that um ashley as the tortoise
gordus is one of the best things in
gaming like
it she's so adorable that it like it
hurts me i'm like that
it's just it's and coming off of i like
played that right out of the last of us
and so the the whiplash of like this kid
who has to grow up too soon and is
surrounded by
death into just the cutest little circle
it killed me i was like this is amazing
i love that game that was one of the if
you've never played it i don't know if
can you find it anymore because
is it not on steam anymore uh well i
mean last i heard telltale was pulling
every
everything was off you know because they
shuddered yeah
verify that if you haven't played by the
way if you can still find telltale games
um i obviously have no skin in the game
with this because they're
they're done skis and fortunately most
of the incredible
amount of talent from the writers the
animators uh character modelers have
somehow found
fertile soil by which to plant
themselves and grow and others
ad hoc now working on wolf among us
it looks like it's still there although
it's it's tough because it it says it's
already in my library so i can't tell if
like i'm getting a special store page
that if i hadn't bought it
i wouldn't be seeing it but you should
looks like it's still there
obviously wolf among us and walking dead
are fantastic titles that they did
but the lesser known ones back to the
future
is the fourth movie and tales from the
borderlands
i you'll cry like it's it is a there are
beautiful
moments in there it's it's easy for
games to make us cry
except for elan appears because a lot of
pierce typically doesn't cry during
movies or games
um but she will at a book um
but the uh
for a game to make you laugh it's really
hard it's really hard to do
comedy in games because players have
control of timing i find that so
fascinating
yeah how do you use comedy when you
can't control timing but also so a few
people even
no no i cut you off but
people don't even tr like tim schafer is
one of the few
reliably trying over and over to find
new ways of making video game comedy for
for
many many many years but i feel like
it's just mostly underdeveloped
as a subcategory of games did a great
job
yeah south park game is amazing both of
them i loved
tim schafer and not i'm not sure to be
reductive or disparaging at all but tim
schafer
has a tendency to just kind of go either
fantastical or rompy
um and they're still hilarious they are
they're
they're funny but the thing that
especially tells the borderlands did was
the subtlety and the nuance and the
downplayed of like
heist as a comedy kind of feel um
and that is a credit to everyone that
worked at telltale but specifically to
nick herman and pierre shorett
like those two guys as writers both of
them have found great homes
um but the anybody who's ever had the
opportunity to work with those two guys
would
be fortunate people because they're just
they're just incredible so
i don't know that would be my submission
for like maybe people didn't play this
enough but i'm super proud of that game
fair anyway austin i think i think my
you know i've
scored a lot of things that nobody
played
i've scored far more movies that nobody
has seen
uh uh then i've actually still to this
day scored more films than games it's
going to be it's going to be probably
another few years before those numbers
because the rate of movies that i score
is a lot lower these days so
i just had a few years where i was doing
so many that that
i got out ahead basically um
but um there's one in fact you know what
i'll hijack
that and say that there's a movie that i
did that i was just thinking about the
other night and i was like man it's such
a shame that more people didn't see this
because it's so good which was called a
little help was directed by michael
whitehorn his directorial debut but he
was the creator of the sitcom
king of queens and he wrote on sitcoms
going all the way back to family ties
and
innumerable others very very very well
known and respected name and tv
and he directed a film and it was jenna
fisher pam from the office it was her
first film as the lead actress and
and it's got also um rob benedict and
chris o'donnell
and we did this 10 years ago i scored it
2010
and it no one saw it and it is so good
and and it's not what you're expecting
like because the office was
still like very much i think it was
still going um
uh in 2010 right it had to have been um
and um
so the popularity you know she's very
much associated with comedy and the
movie is a comedy but it's a dark comedy
about people who are broken in life like
she it's not a slap sticky movie at all
the the premise of it
it's a very twisted premise and actually
kind of ironic given that we just passed
the
um the um anniversary
of september 11th because the movie
takes place one year after september
11th
in uh new york and the great center for
comedy
the premier that's the thing that this
is michael michael jokes right
themselves right
yeah he he the premise is that um
at the very beginning of the film jenna
fischer her character's name is laura
her husband
uh dies of a heart attack and they have
a very broken marriage and they have
this kid who's about 10
who wants nothing to do with her he's
very fixated on his dad
and the dad doesn't really care about
the kids so it's just like a triangle of
sadness
and um the dad then dies leaving her
with this kid that she has no connection
with
and then he changes to a new school
and uh the school year starts it's the
one year anniversary of 9 11 and the kid
lies and
because his dad has just recently died
of a heart attack
he lie everyone says where's your dad
and he lies and says my dad was a
firefighter who died in the towers
and then jenna fisher uh in a desperate
attempt to bond with her son
when the faculty call her to basically
verify that she
she leans into his lie and has to live
in that lie with him
and it's but the movie is it's it's so
much more than just that for a movie
about people it's just about people
trying to figure out life and and her
performance i actually got to visit the
set while they were shooting and i
just knew her as pam and i was like
she's a real actor she's
nothing like pam and she's nothing like
her character in this like
i was blown away and it was one of those
the movie she remember
she went on a uh like conan o'brien or
one of the late night talk shows to
promote the movie when it was coming out
and she was pregnant at the time and all
they talked about was being pregnant
they didn't talk about the movie
and then and then the interview was over
and then the movie came and went and i
was like and and jacob dillon from the
wallflowers he wrote original songs
uh for it and sony colombia put out the
soundtrack album that has even some
score on it and all that we had all the
dice loaded
and still no one saw it and i mean maybe
it sucks but i thought it was amazing i
thought the movie
put it on the list yeah i don't even
know where you'd find it i don't think
it's on netflix
never mind how about you mike
do you have a throw to that um i like i
like the
well we've got a minute so i'm going to
say dead right retribution is one i
worked on that i just
i feel like that game deserved more of a
moment because it was this really nice
combination of
melee combat and gun combat that was way
ahead of its time
but i was only a very junior kind of
designer on that
uh but anyway we're running out of time
we are running out of time thank you so
much
so much oh you're fine that's all good
um i did want to like quickly answer the
question everyone keeps asking is what
are you guys going to do when the
pandemic is over
um everyone's like are you going to be
in the same room well mike lives in a
different country
and we have jobs and we record during
the week so i don't know that we will
ever record this show in the same room
um but i'm hoping we can keep up the
consistency
every now and again under normal
circumstances this would have been a
live
panel in person had the pandemic not
happen so we'll certainly try to do
it at a conference or something but i
don't think the format of the show will
change
because i ultimately do this show on my
lunch break so i can't really like drive
somewhere or whatever on a lunch break
doesn't really work do you think we'll
go back to monthly or do you think this
is now just a thing that all four of us
i don't want to i like doing the show
too much but i guess we'll see
uh we'll have to figure out the lack of
the lack of travel uh
has made it really easy to stomach uh
that that time
because travel usually is a big uh my
guess
my if i had to pick if i had to make a
prediction in the spirit of our
playstation
pricing thing i think a happy medium
would be bi-weekly
yeah uh uh probably you know because a
month is a long time like just think
about that between the first and second
episode where it's like okay
all the mandalorians finished the new
star wars it was like there's like too
much to unpack
too much yeah but but we'll figure it
out and we'll keep you updated
um thank you everyone tuning in to
watching the show live
uh yeah merch drops on friday
redbubble.com
people play watch listen can't wait to
see everyone wearing it we'll see you
guys next time